I saw barbie yesterday
they asked me to see Barbie
the daily wire asked me to see Barbie
because
Ben talked about it and Ben's very harsh
critique of Barbie made national news
and so before the backstage show last
night which is where I gave most of my
view on Barbie I won't belabor it too
much now uh
they said okay see it and see if you
agree with Banner if you disagree with
Ben because it's probably going to come
up on the show
I said Okay meet sweet little Elisa we
go watch the movie
I intentionally
did not watch or read any reviews before
the movie I saw that Ben hated it
so I saw the little clip of him throwing
the Barbies and setting them on fire in
the trash can I saw that some other
people hated it and I saw that some
other people liked it and I noticed
without reading any reviews or see
watching any reviews I saw that some
people and some social media accounts
that I really like and admire liked
Barbie one of my favorite all-time
Twitter accounts Edmund smirk uh
eudaimonia for a very sharp fella you
dimonius girlfriend shoe on head who's a
leftist but she has interesting takes I
noticed they all kind of liked it I
noticed that my friend Brett Cooper here
liked it but then a number of my other
buddies on the right up to and including
Ben Shapiro they hated Barbie so I
wanted to go in with a totally fresh
slate not colored by anyone else's views
I hadn't even really maybe I watched the
trailer I don't even really remember
watching the trailer and I go in
[Music]
it's great
I was primed to like it because
one it's always fun to disagree with Ben
but you know sometimes Ben and I agree
and two because Greta Gerwig did a great
job with ladybird her movie that came
out in 2017 I thought was really really
excellent so I already had this sense
that Greta Gerwig is not some just crazy
radical who gets everything wrong
ladybird is a very conservative movie
and so I I watched it
guys from the very beginning it's not
even particularly ambiguous that Barbie
is a conservative movie the short
version of it is it opens up with this
this homage to 2001 Space Odyssey and
see some little girls playing with their
baby dolls and they're having a nice
time then Barbie comes in as this icon
of feminist progress and the girls
start killing their babies
which if that doesn't sum up feminism I
don't know what does then they go into
Barbie land which is a feminist Utopia
and they show all the different types of
Barbies Dr Barbie president Barbie this
Barbie that Barbie then they get to
pregnant Barbie and the narrator comes
in and says oh yeah that one was
discontinued we can't have pregnant
Barbie here in Barbie land but you know
a woman can be anything but you can't be
pregnant
already that's a very strongly two very
strongly anti-feminist moments clearly
intentional clearly very precise then
you go on through Barbie land
everything's fine it's all about Barbie
all the men are just simps all the Ken's
are just kind of simp
who just do whatever Barbie wants
and they have no identity outside of
Barbie and then then something starts to
crack
Barbie becomes dissatisfied with this
eternal present Barbie starts to wonder
about death he says wait Am I Ever Gonna
Die what's time what's progress what's
love what's Consciousness she becomes
self-conscious and then this Guru
feminist Barbie weirdo Barbie this is
all spoiler alerts by the way so if you
if you do want to watch the movie maybe
skip a few seconds here uh Guru feminist
Barbie comes in and says okay you can
choose the red pill or the blue pill you
can choose either the high heels
pretty high heels or you can choose
Birkenstocks you know of reality and and
so Barbie says Okay I want the pretty
high heels
I want the blue pill
and this is really
significant I think feminist Barbie goes
oh no I was presenting you with the
illusion of a choice but you don't
really have a choice you have to do the
gritty awful terrible
you know Birkenstock thing which is
reminiscent I think of Simone de bevoir
the French feminist who in a debate with
Betty Friedan once said we can't give
women a real choice
yeah we can we pretend that women have a
choice to either stay at home or go out
to the workplace but they can't really
have that choice because if women have
the choice to stay home and live a
traditional life too many of them are
going to choose family and children and
husbands so they have to basically be
forced out into the workplace and that's
what you see in Barbie land so then
Barbie goes into the real world
and Ken goes with her and Ken says wow
the real world is a patriarchy oh man
this is great and this is where uh Ken
joins the manosphere right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show let
me ask you something when you use the
restroom you always close the door
behind you right you don't want random
passers-by looking in on you so why
would you let people look in on you when
you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
in a one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
Barbie and Ken go into the real world
and they see that the real world is not
controlled by all these feminist girl
bosses the real world is controlled by
men people in the c-suites in the really
public positions of power they're all
men
now
that's not the end of the story
because
what one begins to notice is the the
people who are actually driving The
Narrative of this movie forward it's not
the men the men are kind of goofy
it's these women in private little
actions a woman who's drawing a Barbie a
woman who's having thoughts about Barbie
is actually the one who's changing the
world and driving the whole plot forward
and then we find out by the end
that the the woman who invented Barbie
or that the person rather who invented
Barbie is a woman this woman played by
Rhea Perlman and she has a very
significant line here when Barbie finds
her and says hey wait women work at this
Mattel company too women women work in
this real world too
Rio perlman's character this god-like
Creator character who who built Barbie
she leans in she says women do more than
work here women do more than work
feminism tells you that a woman going
out and working and having a job is the
only thing that matters it's the most
important thing the conservatives will
tell you what are you talking about
going out and having a job it's fine but
there's so so much more important
there are so many more important things
in life having children having a family
being The Hand That Rocks the Cradle is
the hand that rules the world
that line very hard to see how that line
is not intentional anyway Ken gets
radicalized he says wait a second in
this real world it's The Men Who call
the shots not the women so they go back
and Ken becomes this uh nanosphere kind
of guy you know he has the the the Kaza
Kaza Bunga I forget what he calls it but
it's kind of a funny name for the Ken
house now and in the kendum he dresses
up in this really peacocking way but he
doesn't know how to be a real man
and this
I'll skip over some stuff in the middle
uh I I wish I could go on for hours
about Barbie but we don't have time for
it uh by the end
Ken realize no I just Barbie all I want
is you even when I'm peacocking and
bragging all I really want I just feel
like I'm only Built for you and I'm just
here to serve you and I have no identity
outside of you and Barbie doesn't choose
Kent this is one of the reasons why the
conservatives have been saying this is a
woke movie because Barbie and Ken should
end up together right no no
Barbie land is a feminist Utopia
it seems in theory kind of nice I guess
it's really just a fantasy for little
children but it's not something's deeply
wrong here
Ken is a product of feminism and so when
Barbie says hey Ken you've got it before
before you just try to throw yourself at
me and we get married or whatever you
need to figure out who you are because
Ken is not the big Alpha Giga Chad
traditional man leading his family he's
a product of feminism he's kind of a
simp he's kind of a he doesn't
he's not the kind of man that a woman
actually wants to marry so when she says
you've got to figure out who you are
this is a message for boys who are
raised in this feminist worlds that
unfortunately we live in it's it's not a
knock on the boys this is how they were
raised but they've got to figure out how
to be a man
not just going going along to get along
with the feminist world and not just
reacting against it in some Childish way
that doesn't actually build them up as
proper men you've got to figure out how
to be a man in the real sense of things
so then
Barbie chooses to leave this is another
example the a lot of the conservatives
seem to think that Barbie land is
considered the good place and the real
world is considered the bad place Barbie
land feminist good real world patriarchy
bad
Barbie chooses the real world
the Barbie land is is the bad place
the Barbie land that's why there are all
these jokes about patriarchy she says
the word patriarchy like a dozen times
in there that's a joke that's a punch
line we know it's a punchline because
the ray of Pearlman Creator character at
the end admits at the end of the movie
she says oh yeah people in order to cope
with the ambigu ambiguous nature of this
Fallen World you know in order to cope
with the craziness of this world we just
make things up we make things up like
Barbie we make things up like patriarchy
does this mean we make things up like
the actual structure of the patriarchy
that controls everything or we make
things up like the concept of the
patriarchy just like the concept of
Barbie
I think it's the latter and Greta Gerwig
and interviews has said everything in
this movie is intended to operate on two
levels the movie has
clear Christian imagery I mean she's
admitted that herself Gregory said in
interviews a lot of this comes from her
Catholic School upbringing
even though I don't think Gregory is a
practicing Catholic that's how she was
educated you see it throughout all of
her movies and then to me the the part
where gretiger really shows her hand is
at the very end of the movie after she
admits the patriarchy yeah it's just
that's like a fake make-believe concept
to cope with the difficulties of the
world
Barbie's happy vision of the future
which is why she chooses reality which
is supposedly a patriarchy is not being
a girl boss and going to work at some
widget Factory it's motherhood
it's family even the mother and daughter
in the in the real world which is a
driving theme in the film it's not even
just like a single mother who's angry
well she's married she's in a kind of
traditional relationship even though her
husband
in the real world is kind of a Ken
he's he's been he's been castrated by
the feminist culture as well so there's
a problem to work out there in the real
world
and the things that women complain about
in the real world and in Barbie land
their their complaints
about what feminism has done not about
what tradition is done
we're expected to be girl bosses we're
expected to have jobs the final scene
Barbie walks in you think it's going to
be the apotheosis of the whole feminist
journey in the movie and she's going to
go get her job in the real world no
they say what are you here for ma'am she
goes I'm here to see
my gynecologist
which is a surface level joke about how
Barbie dolls don't have genitalia
it's a deeper joke which ties in with
the entire thesis of the movie and every
theme from the very first shot of the
movie which is oh no what really matters
here
motherhood one of the lines one of the
key lines from this exasperated real
world woman talking in Barbie land she
says I I want a Barbie I don't want a
Barbie that's the president I want a
Barbie that's a doctor I don't want to I
want a Barbie that says it's okay just
to be a mom
that's that's one of the realizations
this woman had woman has during the
movie
Gerwig is great now I know some people
are saying Michael you're reading too
deeply into this first of all Greta
Gerwig literally says in interviews hey
you should realize there there is a
double meaning here to the movie as
there was in Lady Bird but first but I
guess my other answer to that is
um
what do you what do you think is more
likely that gretiger wig just
accidentally
fills all of her movies with these very
precise deeply meaningful
points from beginning to end of all of
her movies
or that she's doing it intentionally
or at least artistically
it's not just an accident it's not just
oh yeah you're reading a little too much
into every single moment of her movie
that's coherent
the the argument against Barbie to say
it's so super woke the best argument
people can muster is oh it's an
incoherent movie I don't think it's
incoherent I think it's extremely
coherent I've explained a little bit of
how coherent it is uh what's more likely
seems to me also it's just a nice piece
of filmmaking because it's fun and you
know the performances are good and
they're singing and dancing and it's
very colorful
that's a good movie guys it's a good
movie
really
I don't I don't think I'm allowed to
remain a heterosexual married man with
children if I talk about Barbie for even
one second longer but
I left the movie more optimistic about
the culture there are a lot of people
out here Drew made this point last night
at Backstage there were a lot of young
women who wouldn't call themselves
traditionally conservative or Christian
or right-wing or whatever who are waking
up and recognizing feminism is really
bad people who in recent years would
have called themselves left-wing
feminists liberals whatever who are
turning against birth control who are
turning against the hookup culture who
want to get married who want to have
children who want to do normal things
okay
I think this would be a sign of those
times boy what a great clip that was huh
make sure you subscribe ring the bell to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel see
you next time